uma das coisas mais legais do ted pelo
menos uma das coisas que mais gosto é
que dá oportunidade de falar sobre uma
coisa que é absolutamente apaixonado
pelo mundo assim e por mais que você
fica até meio nervoso nem falar em
público tudo mais só tinha pra falar eu
fui muito apaixonado por aquilo então
acaba sendo uma quase que natural fazer
isso e eu vim aqui falar de uma coisa
que eu sou absolutamente apaixonado que
a educação é eu percebi ao longo de toda
a minha vida a importância que isso tem
para mim
enfim todo mundo aqui tenham sua relação
com a educação de alguma forma foi o
caso de alguma forma mas acho que o que
eu quero falar aqui é um pouco de como
aprendi sobre a educação fora da sala de
aula né
grande parte da relação que a gente tem
com a educação eo primeira coisa que
realmente aquilo na sala de aula o
professor
enfim é o sinal do do intervalo e quase
tudo o que eu aprendi ao longo da minha
trajetória foi fora da sala de aula mas
que a sala de aula tem sido muito
importante eu tenho 24 anos hoje e eu
passei desses 20 e 45 anos do movimento
empresa júnior é dar mais ou menos 20%
da minha vida a gente não pode fazer
conta então e foi impressionante porque
esses 20% da minha vida mudaram
radicalmente a minha forma de ver o
mundo ea partir desses 20% de vida eu
decidi que a educação é uma das causas
que eu quero seguir
eu queria mostrar um pouco disso um
pouco dessa mudança radical de
pensamento que eu tive conta uma
história que foi bem legal inclusive
usando esse mesmo para todo mundo agora
essa foto foi tirada no passado em julho
de 2014 em genebra na suíça
muito chique né é essa foi a primeira
viagem internacional eu nunca tinha
saído do brasil eu não tinha passaporte
eu tive que correr desesperadamente para
tirar um passaporte porque na verdade a
história dessa foto é que ano passado eu
era vice presidente da confederação
brasileira de juniores nesta brasil jura
e ver este meu amigo está ali na foto
ele era o presidente e me convidaram
convidaram e também a fase a falar no na
assembléia
a europa ou seja o órgão máximo de
empreendedores na europa sobre como a
gente desenvolve empreendedorismo
universidades brasileiras
é basicamente isso aí que vocês falam
sobre casos como esses fazem isso é como
se desenvolve em empreendedorismo e tudo
mais e fomos lá nós né
eu fui lá corrigir o passaporte quase
foi barrada na saída do brasil
depois quase foi barrada na volta mas
acho que essa história para o momento é
não se a barra não sei se enfim não
levaram muito a sério mas foi
interessante combinar a gente pra isso e
quando a gente chegou lá a gente decidiu
cara a gente não vai falar só das nossas
práticas de desenvolver produzir nada
disso vai começar a falar da nossa visão
de brasil
depois ele vai falar de como a gente
entende o papel do universitário do
jovem empreendedor na transformação do
brasil em prol dessa visão que a gente
imagina
depois a gente vai falar no final de
tudo como a gente enquanto confederação
consegue fazer esse trabalho e é se essa
experiência muito marcante para mim não
só por ter sido meu primeiro prêmio
internacional mas porque o final dessa
apresentação as prestação na verdade é
dura uma hora depois de terminar a
prestação convidaram a gente a continuar
por quatro horas e transformou num
workshop cancelar o resto da programação
da assembléia ea gente ficou quatro
horas falando sobre como a gente no
brasil desenvolve empreendorismo
universidade e no final é um dos líderes
do movimento na europa na frança
desculpa e uma empresa nasceu na frança
ou seja é bem relevante isso ele chegou
para mim e falou uma frase que eu nunca
vou esquecer
eu espero que um dia as pessoas do meu
país consigo falar dele com orgulho e
com a paixão que você fala do brasil
e naquele momento eu percebi que alguma
coisa tinha mudado de mim e pra explicar
um pouco o que eu achava que tinha
mudado em voltar um pouco no tempo
em 2009 eu entrei na faculdade né
calouro descobrindo ainda como é que o
mundo funciona descobrindo como é que a
universidade funciona e vocês devem
saber exatamente que eu tô falando meio
perdido meio que vai acontecer mas foi
legal porque quando escolheu o curso lá
e entrei para a faculdade
a única certeza que eu tinha na vida é
outra faculdade
vou fazer o curso que quer fazer vou
sair vou ter emprego certo vou falar do
executivo é um dinheiro porque porque eu
não sei se você acompanhar mas eu gosto
muito de economia ea capa dela na çã
era essa brazil takes off setembro de
2009 que acaba de entrar na faculdade ea
grande perspectiva do mundo em relação
ao brasil é o brasil é o país da década
é o país excepcional é o país vai
crescer e vai se desenvolver tudo mais
vai ser o grande país dos próximos anos
ea encaminha um pouquinho pra frente né
depois do teu acaba de entrar na
faculdade saindo um pouco da minha fase
de calouro indo para 2013 é que foi um
ano anterior
aquela experiência na suíça é nesse ano
eu era presidente da federação de
empresas juniores do rio
estou me candidatando para a vice
presidência do brasil juliana naquele
processo de candidaturas prepara
proposta e tudo mais e logo eu lembro
que eu estava escrevendo a proposta e só
em setembro de 2003 setembro outubro de
eu por acaso fui ver de novo economista
naquelas investidores muito legal
e essa era a capa da economist no final
de 2013 popa
ou seja basicamente que ele está falando
é então lembra que quatro anos atrás e
falou que era o brasil da década pô
erramos de desculpa formal do negócio
também ruim e e econômico no vídeo
fiquei muito impactado não é porque eu
entrei no governo precisa júnior era o
brasil era a bola da vez e quando o cara
me candidatando por um carro por a
confederação brasileira para representar
o brasil
o negócio estava já mas não tão certa e
eu fiz uma pesquisa rápida na semana
passada para buscar alguns dados sobre o
brasil e eu vi que hoje o brasil tem
119º e desenvolvimento econômico no
mundo de acordo com o fmi ou seja já que
pra gente conseguir bem estar em um
partido desenvolve precisa crescer
economicamente pode ver que depende está
um pouco difícil no brasil mas a gente
pensa cara brasileiro um povo muito
trabalhador a gente consegue enfim
empreender ações para mudar essa
realidade
mas o nosso país criando ou não ainda
também está bem ruim produtividade de
vice do fórum econômico mundial e tem um
dado que é meio triste nenhum alemão
produz quatro vezes no brasileiro produz
óbvio que não por conta do trabalho do
brasileiro que a gente sabe que é um
povo trabalhador mas por conta das
circunstâncias e não só por conta das
circunstâncias principalmente com de
educação assim como a gente fala de
educação superior que é o que o
movimento empresa júnior busca melhorar
a gente também não está muito melhor
a gente está em 40º lugar no sistema de
educação superior no mundo
então dependendo da educação superior
para melhorar a produtividade e agente
de desenvolvimento econômico é um pouco
difícil assim
essas relações não está encaixando muito
bem mas é muito doido isso porque depois
de ver todos esses dados quase que
falando que o brasil que perdeu sua
chance de ser a bola da vez
hoje sou muito mais patriot muito mais
otimista em relação ao futuro do brasil
o que é meio contrassenso né eu entrei
muito bem agora o brasil também o mal
mas eu estou mais feliz e otimista com
ele apesar de tudo né
e porque é tipo sei lá não faz muito
sentido pra pensar
eu comecei a tentar buscar isso dentro
de mim é cara porque eu fiquei tão feliz
e consegui falar com tanto orgulho do
brasil lá na suíça para o cara que chega
pra mim falar pô ilegal naquele a forma
como você falou do brasil
eu comecei a perceber que o sufoco isso
foi bem como conhecer uma empresa júnior
entrei
enfim na universidade eu lembro que em
2009 quando tinha entrado na faculdade
era calouro tem aquela recepção de
calouros todos vocês já conhecem aquela
recepção de calouros que eu tive eu
lembro de um cara super bem vestido
subiu no palco ele tivesse 12 anos mais
velho que eu
o dia 18 para ter seus 20 anos e ele
começou a falar sobre empresa júnior
assim como é que a empresa júnior como
funcionava e tal que quer a experiência
está numa empresa júnior
ele começou a falar de como aquilo era
uma grande oportunidade de
desenvolvimento pessoal e profissional
você vai entrar vai aprender a lidar
pessoas a falar em público e tudo mais
e eu lembro que eu me preocupei muito
com ele da falta de oportunidades e
falei cara vai ter 20 anos e fala também
público eu quero isso sim é isso que eu
quero quero e não ter vergonha e falar
fazer tudo mais
eu lembro que me inscrevi num movimento
exagero muito pensando nisso cara é
tóquio pode mudar o brasil não era minha
premissa inicial porque era mudar o
brasil não quero ser o cara falar falar
no palco porque é muito legal quero ser
o cara que vai se desenvolver
profissionalmente e pessoalmente o seu
melhor estágio por aí vai
mas o que eu aprendi o movimento empresa
júnior e talvez essa seja a grande
mensagem eu posso passar sobre o
movimento empresa júnior é que mais do
que uma oportunidade de se desenvolver
que acontece é uma oportunidade de mudar
radicalmente a maneira como você vê o
mundo e isso me tornou mais otimista mas
diferenças em relação ao brasil porque
quando eu entrei na universidade o que
todo mundo me falou que eu ia ver só
teoria da sala de aula
eu tenho uma teoria
supostamente referenciada na realidade
que supostamente aplicava como mundo
funcionava para um dia quando saísse da
universidade eu poderia ir lá aplicar de
alguma forma inversamente funcionava e
aquilo é a educação que me ensinaram a
educação é o pará houve o game
transferir conhecimento ea partir disso
tentar desenvolver
enfim a minha maneira de pensar no
governo brasileiro pcb poderia ser
diferente ela aprende na prática eu
comecei a ver o que dava para fazer
projetos reais para pessoas reais com
problemas reais e que muito
provavelmente não teriam acesso a esse
tipo de conhecimento de outra forma
seja porque num mercado muito caro seja
porque eles não fizeram universidade
seja porque está empreendendo pequeno
negócio não faz idéia do que fazer e aí
eu comecei a ver que esse modelo de
educação um pouco diferente
outra coisa que eu sempre ouvia é que
quando você sair do da universidade
entrar uma grande empresa
você vai lidar com indiferença vai dar
um número o qual o seu número 10 84 e
pronto você é um número daquela
organização e um dia quem sabe com muita
sorte com muito preparo e com muito
conhecer as pessoas certas talvez você
um dia chega a ser gerente diretor de
uma empresa
e aí quem sabe você possa tentar fazer
diferença na vida de alguém se tiver
espaço para isso no momento eu percebi
que não era tanto assim
eu percebi que mesmo com 20 e poucos
anos você poderia assumir uma posição de
liderança com 20 e poucos anos eu
conseguir falar em público falar com as
pessoas mobilizar a gente engajar
pessoas liderado em uma equipe de cinco
ou uma organização de sem fazer
organização de dobrar o faturamento
triplicar o faturamento particular e
tudo mais
eu comecei a perceber que ali ali que há
a liderança ela não depende de patente
eu não me tornava líder a partir do
momento que alguém chegava e falava você
agora o diretor da multinacional
a liderança é muito mais uma questão de
cara eu vou empreender minha vida e eu
vou ajudar as pessoas e as coisas
pessoas à minha volta para empreender o
sonho deles é isso que dá para aprender
isso cedo
outra coisa que eu percebi é que que
sempre falaram no mercado uma selva
competição
a quantidade de avós que já falamos pra
gente de paz também mas preciso que a
voz daquela gerações passadas cara o
mercado uma selva
você vai entrar um puxando o tapete do
outro tentando ser melhor que o outro
tentando subir em cima do outro e toma
cuidado com isso
que você tem que ser melhor que todo
mundo e centro o vento júnior e você
começa a conversar com a empresa que é
do mesmo setor que você que atende os
mesmos clientes que você na mesma área
que você você senta para conversar sobre
como vocês podem ver se junte como esse
podem melhorar suas práticas como vocês
podem melhorar os projetos de estratégia
por aí vai
e como você que faz exatamente a mesma
coisa o cara faz que deveriam ser
concorrente dele todo mundo no mercado
falou que são concorrentes em troca ele
como amigo um cara pra colaborar um cara
pra quem sabe até fazer negócios depois
quando saírem do movimento empresa
júnior e por último e talvez tenha sido
a coisa mais importante que aprendi
noventa júnior foi que sempre me falaram
que deveria trabalhar por dinheiro que
deveria entrar uma organização pela meu
cheque no final do mês pagar minhas
contas é isso que está no trabalho para
sobreviver não para viver se vive fora
do trabalho vão se pegar as suas 24
horas tinham um terço disso
sófia que um terço para ganhar dinheiro
no final do mês não execute algumas
horas do domingo vai jogar tanto mas é
isso que dá pra gente de vida né
e não vou vender eu comecei a perceber o
seguinte que dava pra começar a
trabalhar pensando em amor
dava pra você participar de um negócio
como eu passei por cinco anos de forma
voluntária
só porque você ama só se apaixonado pelo
que você faz para as pessoas que não lhe
pelo propósito você está tentando
construir alguma forma e com isso no
final das contas o o dinheiro vem por
que você está tão apaixonado
você tá tão entregue no que está fazendo
o que você vai fazer alguma coisa legal
você vai aprender algo e com isso você
vai conseguir ter sucesso pessoal e
profissional de alguma forma e onde
estão essas pessoas não já que esses
jovens que estão passando por esse
processo de transformação que na minha
opinião é muito mais um processo de
mudança da forma como você vê o mundo do
que necessariamente um processo de
educação tem vários deles que estão na
platéia tem vários que estão organizando
esse evento que vocês estão participando
mas o que é legal aqui estão espalhados
hoje mais 160 instituições de ensino
superior e por conta da partilha da
criação é da estabelecimento dessas
empresas juniores nessas instituições
a gente tem várias universidades que
agora tem a possibilidade de ter acesso
à educação empreendedora que não teria
outra forma
inclusive em cursos que às vezes não
teriam acesso à administração às vezes
até mais normal é falar não de
empreendedores
tudo mais hoje em dia a gente tem peso
de direito a gente tem uma ideologia de
ciências médicas por aí vai
então a gente está vendo que esses
jovens estão tendo a oportunidade de
transformar educacionais organizadas nas
universidades do praia do brasil e de
promover um tipo de educação que ninguém
nasce a fonte ainda porque não queria
por isso mesmo existe algo parecido
e esses jovens hoje estão fazendo mais
2.500 projetos por ano atendendo aquela
pessoa que muitas vezes na base da
pirâmide que o microempreendedor que o
mei que parece mesmo ter acesso ele sabe
fazer alguma coisa legal ele quer a
partir daquilo tirar seu sustento
subsistência mas não consegue fazer
aquilo dar certo você fazer crescer e às
vezes ele vai propor uma empresa júnior
faz um projeto com 5 10% do valor que
ele vai ganhar no mercado e com isso tem
acesso a conhecimento que não teria de
outra forma ea partir desses projetos
está formando hoje 10 mil jovens líderes
por ano
são pessoas estão passando pelo governo
empresa júnior ea partir disso tão
entrando em organizações do primeiro
segundo e terceiro setor sobre os seus
próprios negócios estão virando
professor estão virando enfim acadêmicos
políticos e por aí vai
e quando eu olho para esse número aí eu
realmente fico muito otimista em relação
ao brasil
aí eu realmente fico muito esperançoso
em relação ao brasil por um motivo muito
simples se você olhar para este número
de forma matemática vocês vão falar cara
10.000 190 milhões brasileiros é
realmente depende disso a gente está num
país tão bem mas eu fico esperançoso por
um motivo muito simples porque essas dez
mil pessoas estão saindo do vento ajudam
e elas não estão protestando elas não
estão gritando elas não estão combatendo
elas não estão tentando lutar
necessariamente com o sistema itália
estabelecido
não que isso seja errado mas mesmo que
eu estou fazendo o que elas estão
fazendo uma revolução silenciosa porque
essas pessoas estão se tornando líderes
empresariais já tem vários empresários
diretores de grandes empresas estão
sobrando líderes sociais algumas das
principais ongs do país foram fundados
propósitos e empresários juniores
funcionando e líderes políticos vários
empreenderam grandes mudanças no nosso
país na gestão pública vai estão se
tornando os professores grandes
professores da universidade e enquanto
eles estão assumindo essas posições
estratégicas dessas organizações
eles estão tendo a oportunidade de mudar
radicalmente
a estrutura da nossa sociedade de mudar
a forma como academia funciona como as
empresas funcionam com mas vamos
funciona e por aí vai
então o que estão fazendo na verdade
aqui no sistema de dentro porque eles
perceberam que a liderança não era
necessariamente bater de frente com o
que estava estabelecido mas ele entrar e
mudar mudar de dentro mudar de dentro
para fora e é isso que me traz esperança
em relação à educação do nosso país
porque a gente começou a tocar pessoas
para serem líderes vão de fato mudar o
país não necessariamente reclamar
o fla está tudo errado mas tentar de
fato empreender uma mudança e isso até
para fechar me lembra uma frase que acho
muito legal de uma socióloga famosa
americana marie emilie que eu me dê
licença poética de mudar um pouco as
palavras até pelos empresários mineiros
conseguirem identificar mais que ela diz
que nunca duvide de um pequeno grupo de
cidadãos conectados capazes e
comprometidos que pode mudar o brasil
porque se tem uma grande certeza que eu
tenho em relação ao nosso país é que
essa é a única coisa que fez essa foi a
única forma que a gente encontrou até
hoje de provocar mudanças fossem sempre
no nosso país
muito obrigado